you remember when that air plane just
kind of like exploded the other day the
national Transportation safety board is
explaining how that kind of third world
accident could happen in America now our
systems group uh began looking at all
the aircraft systems they documented the
entire flight deck and they asked about
the auto pressurization fail light that
did illuminate in three previous flights
there was a decision by Alaska Airlines
to um a restriction actually they put in
place they call it an eops restriction
that uh prevented that plane uh from
being flown to Hawaii over uh water so
that it could if some if some light did
illuminate it could return very quickly
to an
airport so they knew about this